[Music]
in the late 60s
a raucous brand of rock and roll was
thriving in the motor city
artists like mc5 iggy pop
and alice cooper you couldn't be soft
rock in detroit in 68
they were if you were seals and craft
they would just kill you in the midst of
the city's gritty music scene was born a
magazine
as irreverent as rock itself cream
magazine if you want a free copy
3729 cass avenue they're out their
offices
don't cost you any money just send them
a letter with your name and address to
where
3729 cash in detroit michigan the motor
city
cream started above a record store on a
detroit street corner
how would you describe the culture at
the magazine
chaos scott crawford is director of the
new documentary
cream america's only rock and roll
magazine
it's like this ultimate underdog story
um of this
diy it started off as a newspaper and
then became the
eventually became the number two music
magazine on the newsstands
uh to rolling stone what did it mean for
a band to be in cream
well for one thing that was that was the
magazine
alice cooper's debut record pretties for
you
caught the ear of cream's legendary
critic lester bangs
he reviewed our first album as a tragic
waste of plastic
which i always i always loved that
review i always thought that was such a
great review the
tragic waste of plastic you weren't
offended
no it wasn't worth the vinyl that it was
pressed on right
we really didn't put rock stars on
pedestals
which rolling stone tended to do they
were much more reverential towards
artists jan yuhelski was 19 when she
joined cream in 1970. i just knew that
that was where i was supposed to work
had you done much writing before you
started there
oh no i wrote poetry in my bedroom at
night
her first cover story was on smokey
robinson
who just split off from the miracles in
1966
it was smokey me and unrequited love
what a threesome you were my dear abby
my aunt landers my prime confessor you
had
more impact on the teenage dilemma than
claricel
the magazine's mascot boy howdy was
drawn by cartoonist r
crum but its spirit came from the
creative tension between
lester bangs and editor dave marsh
you can strike a balance between
approaching music as politics or
approaching music without being able to
separate it from politics you can't
which you can't separate it though but
see the thing is like if you separate it
i mean what's the point
i mean they literally came to blows at
one point yes they did
it was a marvel to watch it was the
keith richards and mick jagger of
songwriting and that's how he made a
magazine out of out of the fires of ire
as film director cameron crowe who wrote
for cream
remembers in the documentary what they
got to argue about is
why and how to love the thing they loved
and out of that
came like desperate reckless raw
unforgettable coverage of this thing
that they were both in love with
but you cannot make friends with the
rock stars
in crow's 2000 film almost famous
bangs played by philip seymour hoffman
offers advice
to a fictional version of crow these
people are not your friends you know
these are people who want you to write
sanctimonious stories about the genius
of rock stars and they will
ruin rock and roll and strangle
everything we love about it
lester and i before we would go out to
do a story
we would look at each other and we would
really like
work each other out rock stars are not
our friends remember rock stars are not
our friends
but yuhelski briefly became a rock star
when she donned kiss makeup for a story
in 1975.
but the crazy part was that kiss agreed
how did it feel to be on stage behind
all that makeup
it felt amazing you really did feel
bigger than life i think it was a story
that made me a better writer because i
saw what a musician feels
cream flourished through the 70s but
when publisher barry kramer died of an
overdose in 1981 the magazine faltered
and by the end of the decade cream was
done
whatever that thing was that cream had
at its in its heyday
could just never be copied when you
think of that period in time
how do you think of it it was some of
the most fun i've ever had in my life
i say to myself it's like close
encounters of the third kind
where a bunch of people started making
mountains
out of their mashed potatoes and we
experienced something similar
we all came together and i really
treasure
that sense of being one with all the
people i was there with